what appears to be the first steps
towards peace in ukraine russia today
announced plans to drastically reduce
its military activity in northern
ukraine including near the capital kiev
and a face-to-face meeting between both
president putin and ukrainian president
zielinski is now being discussed but
russia says that can happen only after a
draft peace deal is in place well
tonight western governments are
skeptical they are warning that this
could be a move to buy the russian
military more time before its next big
attack
a tense atmosphere in turkey with so
much at stake
ukrainian and russian negotiators hold
their first in-person talks in two weeks
previous negotiations in belarus and
online have struggled to achieve lasting
results
but the mood after this round appeared
cautiously optimistic
the most significant progress since the
beginning of the talks was made today
the ukrainian delegation said it is
prepared to accept neutral status and
not to host foreign military within its
borders
this prompted a promising response from
the russian side
the russian defense ministry has made
the important decision to decrease
military activity several-fold in the
direction of kiev and shernahev to
increase mutual trust and create the
necessary conditions for further
negotiations
in exchange for neutrality and in place
of nato membership kiev proposed a
framework for other countries to act as
security guarantors
these guarantees will be legally binding
and allow those countries to intervene
if ukraine is attacked in the future
the delegation also stressed that any
arrangement would need to be supported
by the ukrainian people in a referendum
but they warned that no treaty could be
signed and no referendum held while
russian troops are still in ukraine
questions on more difficult topics still
remain notably on the status of eastern
rebel territories of donetsk and luhansk
while president zielinski has previously
indicated a willingness to compromise on
the matter the ukrainian delegation was
clear
the position of ukraine does not change
we recognize the international borders
of ukraine as of 1991. there are no
compromises or red lines here
delegates suggested these questions will
be addressed at a higher level opening
the door for potential talks between
presidents zelensky and putin
yet even as talks are underway
shelling continues
footage from tuesday morning captured
the moment that a russian rocket struck
an administrative building in mykolave
killing at least seven people
a timely reminder of the high stakes
behind these negotiations
and for more now we want to go to our
correspondent dorian jones he is in
istanbul tonight dorian it's good to see
you
help us understand what we're seeing
here we've got ukraine saying that it
would adopt a neutral status in return
for security guarantees is this in line
with what russia is demanding
well russia hasn't given any formal
response to these what was discussed uh
in these tuesday meetings uh i mean to
be honest there's a lot of ambiguity
over the nature of the guarantee uh
status that the ukrainians are demanding
from these eight countries which include
poland turkey and israel and what would
be the nature of how they would protect
ukraine if it was uh attacked again and
even the ukrainian delegation were
unclear too one that one member of the
delegation said it would be like nato
they would be an attack on one is an
attack on all which would mean that all
eight countries would have to presumably
uh come militarily to the support of
ukraine but another uh delegate
suggested uh possibly it would just be
an air a no-fr a no-fly zone will be
established over ukraine and arms would
be supplied to the country so it's these
technicalities and fine details which
probably would shape moscow's response
but the key thing here at the moment is
that they are talking about these key
issues of resolving the conflict and
they do appear to be talking them in a
serious way which probably is the first
time since this conflict started yeah
and it prompted the turkish um foreign
minister today to say that these are the
most
meaningful
steps progress steps that we have seen
since the start of negotiations
would you agree with that and i mean
we're not coming very far to begin with
are
we well exactly i mean to be honest it
doesn't say much at all because the
previous meetings achieved very little
indeed so any progress is going to be
significant but having said that there
does appear to be a different mood
following these talks the music mood is
much more positive both delegations are
saying that the talks were positive and
constructive and i think that that's a
reflection of what's happening on the
ground in ukraine where the ukrainian
forces do appear to have fought the
russian forces to a standstill at least
for now so there is a stalemate possibly
and that i think is creating a possible
window of opportunity for diplomacy to
resolve this conflict whether that with
a status in the conflict in ukraine
remains will be possibly possibly key to
whether the present apparent progress
continues
and we know that russia said today that
it plans to radically cut back its
military activity near the ukrainian
capital
kiev
how is this being read dorian i mean is
this a sign that russia is really
ready to step back to an extent in this
war
well i think russia does suffer from a
big credibility gap for what it says and
what it does is recall that russia was
promising it would have no plans to
invade ukraine well that proved not to
be true so i think ukraine has a great
deal of distrust over russian offers and
commitments i think the reality is that
they'll be looking very carefully at
what that means on the ground whether
russia is sincere and what it means what
does it mean by significant are these
major rocket strikes and attacks going
to come to an end and i think that what
happens there will be very key to what
happens going forward whether there will
be an opportunity for further progress
if things are proved on the ground in
ukraine i think that that will be a very
important boost to the efforts to bring
an end to this conflict and ultimately
the goal of bringing the russian and
ukrainian presidents together dory you
said the mood music right now these
talks is positive and i'm wondering is
this building a crescendo that will that
will end in face-to-face talks between
both presidents ukraine and zielinski i
mean is that where we're headed how
realistic is it that we're going to see
that happen
well let's be clear i think all sides
agree that the only way this conflict is
going to end is when the two presidents
sit down now the ukrainians have been
offering talks even before russia
invaded and moscow is refusing saying
that they will only sit down when there
is something tangible to discuss where
there is a framework where there is not
be where there is a realistic chance
that there will be success now this is
what these present talks are all about
creating a framework and turkey the
turkish foreign minister is saying that
they are now looking to the next step of
bringing again the russian and ukrainian
foreign ministers together if that can
if that occurs and if there is more
progress there then possibly possibly
that can create a possible meeting
between the two presidents and the
chance to bring an end to this conflict
but we have a long way to go
i'm very on dorian jones in istanbul but
the latest tonight dorian thank you
and our coverage of these peace talks
continues here at the big table with me
now is our reporter natalia
smaletsevashi has been monitoring
today's talks to tell you let's talk
about
the offer that we're hearing or that
we're getting from russia there's a lot
of skepticism in the west
about how serious russia is now that
we're five weeks into this war i mean
what's your assessment i mean can we
believe russia
well in russia itself
these talks have been also met with
what i'd say will be a cautious optimism
um
it was obviously widely reported on the
russian media and what they say is that
this is a meaningful progress and this
work meaningfully i guess it's the most
positive um description of what's
happening in istanbul and
russian media said that russia is
actually going two steps forward towards
the escalation these two steps meaning
they
reduce reduction of military activity
there and the possible
possible meeting between two presidents
putin and zelensky and this i think can
be one of the most significant outcomes
if it will happen from these talks
because even several weeks ago we
couldn't imagine putting sitting at the
same table with zelinski because he
actually called
authorities in kiev a bunch of nazis and
drug addicts and now if he actually
going to be sitting at the same table
with the landscape this will mean that
russia actually recognizes the
authority in kiev
all right and we've
we want to hear from the russian
negotiator right let's take a listen
after today's meaningful discussion we
reached an agreement
by which a meeting between the heads of
state would be possible at the same time
as the foreign ministers draw up a
treaty
especially because while drawing up and
confirming details of the treaty
it might be necessary to agree some
political nuances and details
if the treaty is prepared quickly
and the desirable compromise is found
the possibility of peace will become
much closer
yeah this peace treaty what are russia's
conditions for peace
well today the talks russia hasn't
voiced any conditions actually they've
listened to what ukraine had to say and
said that they will take this um
considerations from ukrainian side bring
it back home and discuss it with kremlin
especially with putin so there was no
new information on the russian side
russia's aim for this
war or military operation as it was
called and is still called in russia is
the denuncification and demilitarization
whatever that means it wasn't clear from
the very beginning what it is so this
can mean literally anything
what is important for russia is this
neutral status of ukraine and it was
also discussed today and there was
proposal from the ukrainian side about
the nato about the eu so we'll see where
that goes and also what's very important
is the status of donbass and crimea
russia has never said that or stressed
actually that there was no intention in
occupying ukraine or overthrowing the
regime there even though in the very
first days of the war it seems like that
would be an end goal actually uh getting
ukraine really fast and getting rid of
the government there but now it seems
like because of the military
military losses the russia experience
there it will
actually lower the appetite and will be
possibly happy with outcome of getting
the russian-speaking donbass region or
getting control of this region at least
yeah i mean a lot of people that would
say that that's a big stretch to believe
that russia would be happy um to end the
war with that condition uh what about
this promise or this announcement that
russia is going to scale back its
military activities around
um kiev
is it plausible i mean or is it just
maybe a tactic to buy time
well what we've heard now from the
delegation that the this collision
doesn't actually mean a ceasefire so on
the ground the shelling is continuing
what can it mean it's actually it can
actually be actually stating what's
happening there because russia has um
been not advancing on this in the
northern um part of ukraine and kiev and
chernigev region for some time now it is
that they have been effectively stuck so
it can also just state what's already
there but also it can maintain change of
tactics and some analysts say that
the possible next move can be that the
um
that actually the armies that are
employed there will be sent to the
donbass region and this new goal of
actually circling ukrainian army in
donmas region and effectively getting
this region can actually be also sold at
home as victory yeah we will see if this
if if this regrouping and refocusing if
it actually takes place natalia thank
you
thank you
and from those peace talks to the
situation on the ground in ukraine and
that situation is a mixed picture tens
of thousands of civilians remain
trapped in dire humanitarian conditions
in the besieged port city of mariopol
and in the southern city of mikhala
several people were reportedly killed
when a russian missile hit a regional
government building dozens more were
wounded but ukrainian forces for their
part are recapturing territory from
the russian aggressors
all right for more now we want to go to
our correspondent nick connolly he is in
kiev nick it's good to see you you are
in the ukrainian capital i mean what do
people think of what we're hearing from
russia's deputy defense minister that it
plans to reduce its military activity
near the cap
well people here in kiev brent are
definitely taking those announcements
with a significant pinch of salt just
this evening we've been hearing the
usual bangs in the distance some of that
will be ukrainian anti-aircraft systems
knocking things out of the sky but there
is also artillery fire
nightly daily in the suburbs of kiev
we've also had reports of russian forces
some way out of kiev trying to dig in
building
trenches and other fortifications
seemingly prepared to be here in the
long run but yes as you mentioned
previously they're not doing very well
they're not taking kiev and uh for now i
think people feel like the city has
stood up uh to to that russian force on
its doorstep let's have a listen to what
people hear in kiev on the street had to
say about those announcements from
istanbul today
these are not the first talks and every
time we hear the same thing that they
want to scale down the fighting but in
fact they step it up
i don't think we can trust russia
all their words are worth nothing
we believe that they would not wage a
full-scale invasion
no i don't trust their words
and nick at the same time there seems to
have been wins by the ukrainian army
over the past few days i mean can you
tell us more about that
i think there's no uh there's no kind of
contrast between those things i think
the russians are putting a brave face on
their defeats and a lack of success
around kiev and yes we've had news in
recent days of
european one of the big suburbs of kiev
about 25 kilometers as the crow flies
from where i am here that saw some
pretty atrocious
civilian losses and lots of people have
seen those pictures of the destroyed
bridge and people trying to cross with
their children their pets
lots of civilians died trying to get out
of that town that now seems to be fully
back in control of the ukrainian army
and some of the nearby towns which saw
some of the worst fighting the early
days of this war um seemingly according
to ukrainian source at least now
surrounded by ukrainian forces in the
east of the country closer with the land
border with russia there are some towns
retaken by ukraine just as i'm speaking
to you now i can hear some pretty loud
bangs in the distance perhaps probably
artillery fire so this is all still very
real but a sense that the ukrainian
tactics have paid off not engaging with
direct kind of uh battle with the
russians in the countryside in the open
areas not giving the russians the kind
of battle that they could do well in
instead the kind of guerrilla tactics
and really working hard to deprive those
russian forces of the logistics and the
fuel and the food that they need to keep
on fighting
nick do we have a sense of the progress
or if there has been any progress in
evacuating people civilians
out of cities that are taking a a really
really heavy hit from the russian
military and i'm thinking of mario pole
do we know tonight
maripo particularly has been uniquely
unlucky as it were is a city that's
definitely seen the worst in the way of
civilian casualties during this war we
understand about a hundred thousand
people are still left hundred thousand
civilians that would mean about three
quarters of the population had been able
to leave in recent days and weeks but it
you know these these attempts are never
particularly well organized and there's
lots of chaos and people you know
getting hurt trying to get out even if
some kind of temporary ceasefire has
been organized it's very difficult to
get a kind of accurate uh picture of the
situation on the ground but they just
don't have electricity for the most part
they don't have mobile phone connection
so lots of the time you're talking to
people who've got out previously and
have told tell you about what was the
situation was like three four days
before often they're not able to tell
you about what their their family their
friends who are still there are going
through but the stories are all pretty
much the same stories of people stuck in
cellars for days at a time of bodies
going on unburied just lying on the
streets and people getting so hungry
they hang to break into shops to get
some food just to survive yeah it's
unimaginable and yet it is the reality
there on the ground uw's nick connolly
with the ladies tonight from keeve nick
thank you
and we can talk now to stefan meister he
is with the german council on foreign
relations and an expert in russian
security and foreign policy mr meister
welcome to dw now russia says it's
scaling back operations in order to
create an atmosphere of trust
can we really be sure that these peace
talks are happening in good faith
i think it is first of all a strategic
move from the russian side um to to
create options uh the whole war is not
not going how uh putin and the russian
leadership has planned this war uh and
it needs a kind of an option uh to to
have to declare victory and it could
could be about um eastern ukraine but i
think there is no trust yeah i think
there is no trust at all russian
leadership was attacking or russia was
attacking ukraine it was lying several
times on on what are the goals it was
changing also rhetorically its goals so
i think
we have to wait uh until we can really
this can really assess what this this
move now really means
could we see it as some kind of positive
step or should we remain completely
suspicious of what the russians are
saying
no i think it's
it's the most positive step we have seen
in all this war and i think we clearly
understand that that russia has high
loss also of material and of people and
it cannot win this war yeah and it might
stuck for long in ukraine so i think
that there might be a step out of
ukraine in terms of just keeping a part
of it and and then
maybe move later to kiev again but i
think tkf is for the time being not the
main target of the russian attack and
that's that's already positive
um
we're hearing talk of the idea of a
neutral ukraine do you see putin
accepting a neutral ukraine and wouldn't
neutral ukraine in fact ever be enough
for putin and his ambitions
the question is what neutral ukraine
means yeah so i think we don't talk
about austria uh yeah in terms of status
but it is about uh
lack of sovereignty of ukraine no no not
joining any military aliens and not
really having security guarantees but
always being threatened also by russia
and need also to take into consideration
russian interests yeah so i think that's
the neutrality russia is thinking about
and if this kind of neutrality is
acceptable for ukraine then i think
there might be a an agreement yeah but i
think for me this is an alpha mission
what russian leadership is using with
this neutrality term so it's really
about the conditions
um let's talk about the the talks that
have been taking place um in istanbul
today can you describe turkey's role in
all of this
yeah i think the advantage of erdogan is
that he's he's his country is nato
member and at the same time he has a
good relationship with with mr putin uh
he he loves these kind of diplomatic
formats and he's really it's really
upgrading him also yeah his role in
european security at the same time
turkey has really direct interest it has
interest on on stability and security in
the black sea region
um it has economic interest russians are
a major part of tourists also traveling
to turkey um yeah so i think there are
there are several issues turkey has has
really direct interest and i think this
sense it makes sense yeah that that
erdogan is providing this platform
stefan meister with the german council
on foreign relations thanks so much
amnesty international is accusing russia
of committing war crimes in ukraine the
human rights group says that the russian
army is deliberately targeting civilians
and striking hospitals schools and
apartment buildings the invasion has
uprooted more than 6 million people
within ukraine it has sent almost 4
million refugees into neighboring
countries
earlier today dw news spoke to the
secretary general of amnesty
international and asked about those
claims of human rights violations
i think the best way of describing the
situation is to say that the country is
in fire
is on fire we have been documenting an
escalation of human rights and
humanitarian law violations including
the indiscriminate or deliberate
targeting of civilians civilians
infrastructure such as hospital and
schools
we know that in cities under siege
humanitarian corridors are not
functioning trapping people in the in
those
cities we have also documented the use
of weapons which have a
disproportionate impact weapons many of
which have actually
been uh the object of um
of contravention under international law
so the situation right now is one of
major severe
suffering
imposed on the people of ukraine
well here in germany authorities are
discussing banning the use of symbols
such as the z or z that you see here to
express support for russia's invasion of
ukraine
now this letter has become the most
prominent symbol of russia's war efforts
and
is a common sight on russian military
vehicles and pro-russian social media
accounts
germany's intelligence agencies say that
they have evidence that the letter zet
has already been used in germany at
pro-war rallies but also as graffiti
and on vehicles
the letter z as such is of course not
forbidden but in certain cases its use
can mean an approval of the russian war
of aggression and can therefore be
prohibited according to article 140 of
germany's penal code
the russian war of aggression on ukraine
is a crime those who publicly approve of
it can make themselves liable to
prosecution
shortly after russia invaded ukraine
germany's chancellor olaf schultz
announced a historic increase in
military spending it included a one-time
sum of a hundred billion euros to
swiftly upgrade the armed forces and a
pledge to spend at least 2 percent of
germany's gdp on defense every year so
what exactly is germany planning to buy
with all of this money here's a closer
look
these u.s built aircraft are top of the
bundeswear shopping list the f-35 can
carry all types of weapons its design
and coating make it difficult for radar
to detect
with germany's current fleet of fighter
jets aging fast an upgrade is long
overdue
the fm rises
the f-35 is the most modern combat
aircraft in the world
and many of our partners especially here
in europe have also chosen it
together with our partners in the
alliance we'll strengthen our ability to
secure nato airspace
credibly deter
and also if need be defend ourselves
the deal marks a shift in policy instead
of pursuing its own development projects
the bundeswehr is buying what's on the
market even though critics say it
increases germany's dependency on the us
the war in ukraine has made military
modernization even more urgent
when it comes to air defense the german
armed forces are now also considering
purchasing an israeli anti-missile
shield
the system is called arrow 3 and
complements the so-called iron dome to
protect israel against rockets
it can shoot down long-range ballistic
missiles and would be powerful enough to
protect countries in eastern europe as
well
that's something germany so far has not
been able to do but might need to in the
future
we must all prepare ourselves for the
fact that we have a neighbor who's
currently prepared to use force to
assert his interests
and that's why we have to make ourselves
strong together so that that doesn't
happen
also needed new heavy lift transport
helicopters to replace the old sikorsk
gch-53s a system developed in the 1960s
the list of what the bundeswehr needs to
bring it into the 21st century is a long
one from navy ships and tanks to radio
equipment and ammunition easing the
backlog caused by decades of chronic
underfunding will likely take years
a delegation of german lawmakers is
currently in israel to discuss the
potential purchase of israeli defense
systems dw's correspondent in jerusalem
spoke to falco drostman now he's a
member of the governing social democrats
and he's a member of the defense
committee in the german parliament here
is what he had to say about this visit
after the fall of the berlin wall we
believed in peace and we believed in
cultural exchange and economical
exchange and putin destroyed that so
that's why we decided to spend 100
billion euros extra on military
capabilities to strengthen germany and
to strengthen nato we saw all the three
systems we saw the iron dome we saw
david sling and now we saw the arrow 3
which is like like a long-range
capability and of course this could be a
system because it already exists of
course in germany and in europe we want
to develop our own systems but i mean
israel is a strong partner especially in
security industry in weapon industry and
now we have to decide whether this is a
system we can use and we can use quickly